I love this line at the end too.
He says, as a bonus, you get to spend another week after all of this, figuring out how to
do regression testing.
So all future deployments don't have it again and no one accidentally re reintroduces the
bug.
If you're lucky, you'll have someone report that one edge case later that you forgot to
consider and then bundle it with a free consultation about how an ASM product can solve this problem
for you.
Hey guys, real quick.
I just wanted to tell you about our sponsor Threat Locker.
Now wait, wait, before you hit the skip forward button, let me just say this.
Most of the stuff that holds my attention nowadays is red team stuff as well.
But I sat down with the Threat Locker team this past week to do a demo of their EDR software.
And it was super technically fascinating how this thing works.
So check this out.
You drop this thing on a system, right?
And for the first week or so, it's creating a policy and a profile for that system.
It's logging all the executables, what child processes are being spawned, the files and
their hashes, that sort of thing.
And it's creating this policy.
Okay.
Then after the learning mode is up, we're in secured mode and that policy gets put into
place.
And anything that's not on that allow list is immediately auto denied.
That's the zero trust piece, right?
So in addition to that, they've got a bunch of crazy features like ring fencing and dynamic
access controls that would stop a malicious hacker at pretty much every step along the way.
Actually I was watching this demo and I was kind of freaked out because I have no idea how
I would cope with getting dropped into a Threat Locker system as a red teamer.
Anyway, if you want to learn more about this, head over to threatlocker.com and request a
demo.
So if you do ask for my boy, Andrew, his demo was super to the point and he was able to
answer all my technical questions.
All right, cool.
Back to the show.
Man, if only the audience knew the blooper that we just had.
Oh man, that blooper.
We're going to have to send that one to the critical thinkers, I think.
So anyway, let me get back to the subject matter.
I'm prepping for this Defcon talk right now.
And essentially it is a summary of all of the crazy bugs I've found within the past couple
of years.
And dude, that memory of me and you popping that router.
That was, that was the best fan.
That was such a fun bug.
I'm really excited to see what you're able to ask.
Well, what, maybe not what you're able to, but what you're going to say about that.
Yeah, dude, I have like this meme of you and you know, like I want to say it was probably
when, man, I think it was when the hacker one did like a, like a photo shoot in like
the streets of New York back in the day.
And you've got your like hood up and your glasses on and you just look so bad.
And there's a picture of Andre from that same photo shoot.
We posed next to like the same sign.
Yeah.
Oh, really?
Somewhere there's a, there's a Xerox ACP photo as well.
I have to say that that photo shoot that hacker one did with y'all was like one
of my like core motivation features.
You know, like I saw that and I was like, I have to become a live hacking event hacker.
Like it is my fate.
And voila, here we are.
Here you are manifest.
Indeed.
All right, man.
All right.
So we've got a couple of things to hit today before we talk about our primary topic, which
is less writing, more hacking, essentially how to write reports quickly and well for bug bounty
programs.
And I've got a tool I'm going to release with this.
So it should be pretty awesome.
Yeah.
I normally drop these things first to the critical thinkers, but this one, I was like, you know
what, I'm going to, I'm going to just drop this one for everyone this time.
Yeah.
I saw these links in the, in the doc and I was like, these, I, is this like new?
Like, what is this?
That is man.
I just got it PR'd into the project, but we'll talk about that in a second.
Awesome.
News.
Uh, really cool thing happened this, uh, this week.
I saw a, a post, um, on Twitter from the RC man.
And then I saw Gareth Hayes comment on it with one or with two chilling words.
Nice research exclamation point.
Underrated reply.
Seriously.
And when Gareth, you know, when that's coming from Gareth, it's like, okay, we done something
right, you know?
Yeah.
Um, and this was, uh, the, the tweet regarding essentially XSS WAF bypasses by using multi-character
HTML entities.
And from what I can tell, there's just like a bunch of entities that I didn't know existed,
like the ampersand.
And then you do some, you know, ASCII string and then the, the semicolon.
And if it, the, that is being interpreted by the server, um, and, and getting HTML decoded,
uh, even if it's like checking for less than or something like that, there are some, some
weird attributes like, um, ampersand NVGT or ampersand NVLT, which will convert into the
less than and greater than signs plus some other, uh, Unicode character.
Um, yeah.
I thought this was right.
I've never heard of these by the way.
Um, and I don't know if you saw, there was actually a second reply that Garrett sent to
this tweet as well, which was a link to Shazer, which is a tool that we talked about last week.
Um, and well, actually the initial reply is broken, but he followed up with, with a new
fuzz on it.
But Gareth added, uh, a fuzz to Shazer that tests for this specifically and finds all of
the, uh, ASCII or URL encoded values.
Um, that'll work super fast in JavaScript URLs, which is great.
So that now, you know, like what things you can put in there that will actually work and
bypass there.
Yeah.
No, it seems really rad.
And, and essentially it looks like he just kind of hit it with, I'm not actually sure where
he's getting the, the source for all this, but, um, there's a bunch of different strings
you can put in between those, the ampersand and the semicolon sign.
Um, and it's interesting though, because that, if you use the one that he mentioned in the
tweet, it becomes a less than and a string, uh, like a Unicode string.
Right.
So it's like, uh, I'm not sure if this is actually going to, because it's not a valid tag.
So yeah, the, the less than one is a little bit like, uh, I mean, maybe it would work in
those scenarios where HTML, like you're able to trigger an XSS using any HTML attribute.
Like there's some stuff in the PortsWigger XSS cheat sheets.
That's like, uh, you know, this, this on click handler or whatever will work with any element
and they always just use the XSS element or whatever.
Um, so it might work in that scenario, but the one that I'm more excited about is the,
um, ampersand NVGT semicolon, um, entity.
And that one will, uh, do the greater than sign, which will allow you to close off tags,
um, which could be really, really helpful.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
So this is super, super cool.
I love this kind of research.
Um, I'm sure that there are probably some other instances of this as well.
Um, and, uh, the, the Shazer thing from Gareth is actually specifically for URLs.
So, um, one example that he showed is that if you do like a, an a tref with JavaScript
colon one and hat, the semicolon alert one, then that will like work, I guess.
Um, so that's just like a, a very interesting bypass.
There's a lot of, um, these characters and HTML codings that seem to work.
So I definitely recommend you look at.
Yeah.
That one was kind of interesting.
I wasn't sure.
I'm not sure about that one.
I w I want to go and actually check and see if that works.
Cause that doesn't make a lot of sense to me that it would work with that with you're
talking about the one with the JavaScript URL.
Yeah.
That one, I don't know about that one.
I like, I see that he put that in there just to kind of smuggle in the J character or
whatever.
But, um, I think that might only be in some niche scenarios where it cuts off the first string,
but if it actually does work, that would be nuts.
Yeah.
I don't know.
It's super weird.
Yeah.
So actually, you know what?
Let's, let's just, let's just check it out right now.
Hold on.
Let's just, let's, let's just, uh, you know, do the nerd snipe.
Hey guys, real quick.
I just wanted to give a shout to the hacker content team.
They have been absolutely killing it the past couple months, taking the content from the
podcast and condensing it down into consumable social media posts, whether it be shorts or
text posts or whatever they've been rocking it.
So, uh, I just wanted to give them a shout out and let you know that they do all sorts
of cybersecurity content as well as social media management.
They do technical blogs.
They do, uh, comprehensive social media management.
Uh, so if your organization could benefit from any of those types of services, make sure
you head over to hackercontent.com, drop them a line and mention the podcast when you do to
get your first month of cybersecurity content marketing services for free.
All right.
That's it.
Let's get back to the pod.
No way.
Okay.
You can, you can, that, that was crazy.
That does actually work.
Hold up.
This is way cooler than I thought it was.
So this payload, this payload, like, so you're assigning this to location.href, um, via an
on-click handler in an, in an a tag.
Right.
And it's the, it's ampersand F J L I G semi-colon of a script alert one.
And, but that, that character is supposed to convert to F J I thought when HTML decoded.
And I was like, so what is that going to work?
Like, why is there an F just in front of the JavaScript scheme?
Yeah.
Like, it actually works.
Where, where, if you look at the actual href backslash F J A V A S C R I P T, just normal
JavaScript colon alert one.
It pops dude.
Mind absolutely blown.
Super interesting.
And yeah, because backslash F must get converted to a special character.
I wonder if there was like a, yeah.
If you had like a, like a T as well, like there's a variety of different characters that
would fit that criteria that would probably get ignored or something.
Yeah.
Wow.
Very interesting.
I guess, yeah, I guess you're right.
I guess it gets converted.
Like backslash F gets converted to something that.
Yeah.
It gets converted.
Like the backslash stays.
So it becomes backslash F J and then the J becomes backslash F JavaScript.
And then the backslash F is like, must be some special character or something that's getting
ignored.
It doesn't seem like it's anything special, but it must be ignored because it's escaped
or something.
I know that there are definitely cases like that, like in JSON decode and stuff where backslashes
get ignored.
So it could be something similar like that.
But yeah, that's really interesting.
So, and because it's a location, it's like an on click on the a ref.
So it's not, it doesn't look like a link, but it's like clickable elements.
That's crazy, dude.
So I'm looking at this and I looked it up backslash F is a form feed character to indicate
that a printer should start a new page.
So it's like some legacy printer version of backslash N, which of course, if you have that
before the JavaScript scheme, it does work.
Very interesting.
Well, that research is a lot more interesting than I realized when I put it in this, in the
podcast notes.
So if you haven't already, definitely go check out that post by the RCE man, Anton.
We'll link it in the description below.
Wow.
Kind of mind blown at this point.
Yeah.
Super cool.
Super, super cool.
All right.
Let's go ahead and move along.
I'm still a little bit stunned, honestly.
That's really, really interesting.
Let's go ahead and move along to the next one now.
Um, this was, uh, some research that came out this week next to JS cash poisoning and you
can read through it and it's, I mean, there's definitely a good technical write up in here.
Um, but here are some of the takeaways I had from this.
Okay.
Um, one, I think cash poisoning might be the new like subdomain takeover.
Yeah.
I think like, you know, subdomain takeovers, super duper competitive nowadays.
Um, and the recon boys, so to speak are having to pivot into, into different, um, different
attacks, different attack factors to, you know, spray across a mass, um, scale.
And I think that's the best way that this might be one of the best ways to make money through
mass automation at this point is mass scanning for cash poisoning.
And I'm looking at, cause I'm looking at this writeup.
This guy did, and he made a chunk.
I mean, there, there are probably 20 something reports here at least, um, that he associated
with this one bug all, all paid out and accepted and triaged, um, just from this one,
this one thing.
So I think that's going to be the way to go.
Yeah.
I mean, so I think we're definitely seeing sort of the pivot.
I mean, automation has always been like a very fluid sort of thing where, um, it depends
on like what's exploitable in mass and what's, what there's a lot of and like where the competition
is and like how to get that edge and stuff.
And so you've definitely seen like subdomain takeovers sort of being starting to be solved
as a systemic problem where all the providers who are vulnerable to subdomain takeover are
implementing methods where like, they're no longer vulnerable to it.
Cause I think their customers are complaining about it.
Yeah.
I would be too.
Reports and stuff.
So, right.
Like, so, um, you know, cause when you get a subdomain takeover for a third party product,
you're going to reach out to that third party and say, Hey, like we have this issue.
Like how do we fix it?
Right.
Um, so, you know, it makes sense.
Um, but yeah, you're definitely seeing this shift where now like subdomain takeovers are
starting to get harder and harder and more competitive than it's like a super fast race
to claim it first and all that kind of stuff.
So, you know, when you pivot to a more complex vulnerability or something, that's a little
more technical, you get that edge and you do much better payout.
And I think the cash poisoning, the beauty of the cash poisoning thing is it's something
you can validate pretty easily automatically.
Right.
Like if I add this header, does the response drastically change?
You know?
Um, I think that's pretty validatable.
Um, and I know that there are a lot of people doing cash poisoning at scale already.
I've had some good conversations with people, um, about that and building out automation
and making quite a bit off of it.
So, um, definitely, definitely something to look at, uh, there for anybody who's big into
the recon space.
Um, other takeaways I had from this was, uh, just get the code base for whatever, you know,
technology you're trying to look at and just grep for headers, grep for, you know, X,
X dash or whatever.
Right.
Um, and any mention of customized headers within these sort of frameworks and something like
that, uh, there's, there's a lot of possibility.
I think that's a really interesting attack surface.
That's kind of, that's kind of underestimated because a lot of times we're looking for,
you know, parameters and trying to trace the data as it flows through, um, create parameters
or body parameters or whatever, JSON blobs.
But we're not necessarily thinking about, okay, wait, I can also trace my input from custom
HTTP headers.
Um, yeah.
So that, that's definitely another, another attack surface to keep your eye on.
Um, and then the next one was, I just love this quote from this, uh, from this writeup.
It says, quote, the application was cash poisoning itself.
And so the devs added this cash buster.
And I think that that's a really good, um, a really good takeaway from this, right?
Is let's, if you see a cash buster anywhere, the application was likely, you know, cash poisoning
itself.
And the dev is like, oh, how do I fix this?
Ah, cash buster.
Right.
You know?
And, uh, and so I think that's always a good place to look for those vulnerabilities.
Well, and it's also like, again, pull down the source code and look through some of that
stuff, go back.
One thing I love to do is if there's something like a cash buster, for example, and you notice
there's a cash buster on GitHub, click blame.
There's a little button for it.
Okay.
And, and it's, it's a get blame.
It, you know, it's a, it's sounds a little more mean than it is, but really what it is,
is it's a log of every line in the code who committed that line.
And, and you can go and you can view the commit so you can see, okay, the line that added
this cash buster was from this commit.
You go to that commit, you see what PR came from.
It was probably the commit that went and fixed that original cash poisoning.
There you go.
And you look and see, okay, where, where was this affecting?
Where did they fix this?
How do they fix this?
Is there bypass?
Yeah.
Or you, what I thought you were going to say was you run a get blame, you find the developer
that, that did that shit and then you, you look at everything else that they've ever
written in that code base and be like, all right, let's just pick on this guy.
God damn, Justin.
That's hilarious.
Justin's a savage.
Justin's like, I want, I want to take this person and make their life horrible.
Can you imagine if it's like, if you just did that to one developer and like, you just
submit like 15 bugs and they're all from this guy's code base.
That's so mean.
You're just like, I just noticed that John Smith committed this.
Yeah.
Your, your, your, our enemy is like, you know, a dev on an open source project or something
like that.
And he's like tagging him on every issue you file.
Yeah.
You're going down.
Um, so speaking of things at scale, you saw this, uh, this tweet from Nagly, right?
Yeah, dude.
Okay.
So that was kind of a weird situation.
I want to get your take on this as an app set guy.
Okay.
So, um, Nagly, Nagly tweeted out this, um, uh, nuclei template about how exactly to scan
for these, this sort of polyfill IO domain takeover that occurred.
And it's crazy because I've seen polyfill IO everywhere, man.
And, and essentially the situation with this was that domain got sold to bad people essentially.
And now they have like a backdoor on every website that's ever used polyfill.io.
Um, which I feel like there needs to be some sort of like regulation surrounding this at
the domain level.
You know, I, my American is screaming right now saying, freedom, blah, blah, blah.
But like, man, if you have a domain that is so widely used in so many ways, there needs to
be some sort of transfer, um, system or surrounding that applied at the, at the domain level.
Um, because, uh, man, just transferring that away to rogue actors gave a backdoor into like a ton of
websites.
Yeah.
It's super, super wild.
Um, it's really interesting.
So one thing I was thinking about recently is that there's a, there's a new PCI requirement,
um, for anybody who deals with PCI and stuff.
But, um, one of the PCI requirements is that there, you have to have change and tamper detection
on, um, payment and checkout pages.
And not in the sense of like monitoring for code changes, but monitoring for dynamic changes,
is like the scripts that are loaded that are not, um, expected or that they have changed signature
and stuff.
And I think that's a very interesting call out in retrospect on like this sort of vulnerability,
because if any company that has that sort of monitoring would probably have noticed this.
Um, so it's just something, you know, very interesting, um, that I was just thinking about
the connections between the two of those and, and, you know, how it would have played out
from sort of like an app sec perspective.
Um, but yeah, as a whole, I mean, these types of things are like very difficult to find and
detect, like even what I just like mentioned of like monitoring for dynamic script execution
on a website.
It's a very difficult thing to do.
Like you basically have to, you know, use like some headless browser or something like
that to, you know, load the page and then somehow you have to hash it.
And like, yeah, you know, it's very, that's a pretty interesting sort of business idea,
isn't it?
Like monitor the upcoming changes to PCI compliance specs, like, like promise it exists.
Don't worry.
And like say, okay, oh, they're going to like make this requirement for us to have this
headless browser that does change monitoring or whatever.
Here's your, I promise.
If you search PCI 11.6.1, you'll get, there's like at least five or six companies that are
doing exactly that.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Look at that.
Wow.
Crazy.
Yeah.
Well, I, but I mean, like in the future, it's kind of an interesting thing.
Like, like I'm sure there will be changes to the PCI spec in the future.
Um, and I think that they goes through like a review process first where in that those reviews
are public.
Like, so as soon as that gets released and there's a new, a new requirement in place that
requires some sort of technical solution, getting a headstart on devving that, devving
that, devving that, and reaching out to organizations that are going to need it.
I think that's a really, uh, a really great business model.
Yeah.
Um, yeah, absolutely.
Anyway, so it was interesting to see that Noggle released a, a nuclei template for that.
That definitely helps.
I don't know that, I mean, and he's kind of doing it related to shockwave.
I don't know that that would result in bounties.
What do you think about that, Joel?
Yeah.
So I don't like just simply pointing it out is one of those things that I guess it depends
on the program.
Like some programs will probably like maybe as a thank you if they didn't know or something.
Um, I have a feeling it's probably also maybe one of those things that the platforms would
like potentially argue that it's like a zero day or something like that.
I don't know.
Um, I think it's definitely like a, a nice thing to do, but you probably shouldn't expect
a bounty.
Like, you know, if you have the automation set up, like I can see for somebody like Nagly
that it's a good business proposition to be like, Hey, I'm not expecting a bounty.
Just want to let you know.
I have this software called shockwave.
It detected, you know, this vulnerable, uh, software on your website.
You may want to fix that.
Also, if you want to sign a contract, here's my email, like, you know, and like do something
like that.
But, um, that's kind of a unique angle.
He's on top of all these things, dude.
He, he pinged me, uh, a couple of days before the magento thing hit, hit the public and was
like, Hey, this is going to be crazy.
And he, he's got a good, a good feed on that.
So he's got his finger on the pulse.
Yeah.
It's pretty good for shockwave.
Um, what's this other thing you got on here, man?
Okay.
Yeah.
So, okay.
So Sean, yo, uh, you know, friend of the pod, um, he, uh, he tweeted out this amazing,
um, blog that he wrote, I guess.
Um, and it's, uh, it's titled, um, Hey, why can't I get what was the title again?
Hey, why can't you fix this one bug?
Yeah.
And it's, it basically chronicles a researcher, um, being like, you know, imagine you're a
security researcher.
You scan the internet, you find this endpoint on some company, you submit the bug and hoping
for, you know, easy, easy, you know, easy money.
And then you're like, why can't developer just remove the route?
And it's a walkthrough of like the other side of the conversation.
And it's such a great blog.
Um, you know, we've definitely had this conversation, uh, a multiple different times, but I think
this does a great way of illustrating it in more depth on sort of a generic level, um,
of what it's like being a security engineer and like the process that you go through and
the days turn to weeks turn to, you know, whatever, um, as you're just trying to like
figure out how to fix this and who owns it and where it is and what the issue is.
And meanwhile, all the researchers sees is like, Hey, where's my bounty, bro?
Like, why can't you just remove the route?
And the researcher, I think a lot of the time researchers, like they think that, um, every
website is just like a, like a, you know, 30 lines of flask code and like a Python file.
And they're just like, what do you mean?
There's like, there's just a wrap handler.
You just like highlight 15 lines of code, you press delete, and then you save and you
rerun the Python file.
Like what's the big, this shouldn't be this hard.
I was reading through this and I was like, man, this is absolutely me.
Like I am, I am, uh, I'm going through here and you know, every step along the way, he's
like talking about all this, like L seven load balancing and like Lambda this and blah, blah,
blah, blah that.
And I'm like, I have no idea what you're talking about.
Like I consider myself pretty like familiar with, uh, I guess application architecture and
stuff, but like, nah, like, like I only.
I know it from the outside, man.
I only know it from the outside.
And it seems like this is a really interesting read for me because there's, there's so much
more to it than I, than I anticipated.
Uh, and you know, the, the, at one point somewhere in here, he says like, you know,
Oh, I figured out sort of roughly where it is, but wait, I can't touch that.
I don't have privileges to touch that.
And can I get a dev to touch it?
Not a chance.
It's Q2, you know, like nothing happens in Q2.
And I'm like, what?
How does this?
Yeah.
What?
It's so real.
Uh, yeah.
So I would recommend it.
Anybody.
Who's just, I'm sure everybody's had this thought at one point.
That's like, why can't they just remove this?
Like what's like, what's taking so long, whatever.
Read, read through this blog post.
Um, it's a very, it's, it's a short read.
It's very easy to read.
Uh, it's a good read.
It'll definitely put you in the mindset of like what it's like to be a security engineer.
And then I, I would recommend that anytime you're like, what is taking this team so long?
Just pull this up, read through it and be like, Oh yeah, that's why.
I love this line at the end too.
He says as a bonus, you get to spend another week after all of this, figuring out how to
do regression testing.
So all future deployments don't have it again.
And no one accidentally re reintroduces the bug.
If you're lucky, you'll have someone report that one edge case later that you forgot to
consider and then bundle it with a free consultation about how an ASM product can solve this problem
for you.
I did not even play that.
I didn't read that at that end part.
That's so funny.
Which is like, which is like has not, I love how we put that right.
Right after our segment on Noggle too.
Wow.
That's amazing.
That's great.
Anyways, this is, this is a great blog from Sean.
So go check it out on his blog.
I think this is a new blog for him.
Um, mewe.pw.mewy.
Um, but yeah, we, we love Sean.
Yeah.
Sean is great, dude.
Wow.
That's, that's hilarious, man.
All right.
So let's, um, let's get to the topic matter for this week.
Um, and I guess I'm going to go ahead and start with, uh, what's down towards the bottom of
the dock, Joel, which is sure.
Lately I've been thinking, okay.
Um, AI, right.
How can it help?
Lately I've been thinking, Justin's just kind of sitting there in the hot tub.
Hmm.
AI.
I told Justin yesterday that if he had any ideas for how to do something related to the
podcast, that he should write it down and he's out here thinking about AI instead.
Yeah.
No, no.
I was sitting in the hot tub thinking about AI, not those things.
Um, so as I was sitting in the hot tub thinking, hmm, AI, like as I do, you know, I'm thinking,
what are the ways that this can apply to bug bounty hunting and hacking?
And there's a lot of applications that kind of pop into the brain.
Um, but what large language models are best at is dealing with, with text and human parsable
text, really.
Um, they, they do great work with, with code and stuff like that too, but mainly writing
and generating text is, is what it's great at.
When do we have to generate text in the bug bounty flow for the report?
At the worst part.
I'm not, dude, I'm not gonna lie.
I literally like writing reports is, it pushes me over the edge.
It's bad, man.
Like I will literally, I'll find something and I'll be like, is it really worth my time
to write this report?
No.
Is it worth writing the report?
Well, see, and even if I find something critical, I'll be like, ah, now I have to write this up.
Okay.
So I do not have that.
Trying to explain this.
If it's a critical, I'm normally like super hyped to write the report.
I'm like, let me show them how I like did this.
And I like bypass that.
And I went, we, we, we, like, you know, like, that's what's happening in my brain.
That's like a little snapshot of side just for a second.
Um, but, but yeah.
And, uh, and so, but what I don't love writing is the stupid, like reflected XSS reports.
I'm like, okay, here's a quick little reflected XSS.
Like, obviously you can just grab the token and get, you know, account takeover or whatever.
So it's like, it's not a big, there's not like this whole like technical thing.
Normally if there's some cool flow where I like do this OAuth thing and like grab the code and
get ATO, then it's, it feels a little bit more fulfilling.
But when it's like super basic, it's just really annoying.
So, so let's start with that.
Right?
Like the first, the first tip and the thing that I always like, and I know you have something
for this is report templates, right?
I know HackerOne has this natively.
Yeah.
I assume bug crowd and the other platforms probably do to some extent.
If not, just keep a folder on your, on your computer and probably put it on GitHub, which
you Justin.
Yes.
Oh, thank you.
Talking about this repo.
Yeah.
Which, um, yeah.
So, so listen, so listen, here's the thing about the report template thing.
Okay.
Um, I do have a repo, uh, github.com slash rhino writer slash reports.
That is essentially a report template software that I used back in the day when I was doing
a bunch of automation stuff and I was just submitting the same bones over and over and
over again.
Subdomain takeover, body, body, blah.
Then, you know, take the domain, run a dig dot or jig plus trace on it, take the output,
put it in the report, that sort of thing.
Right.
And it's written in Python 2.7.
It's not very long.
Um, I didn't even, cause I'm, well, I'm not, listen, I'm not going to roast you.
It's okay.
It's old.
Dude.
Here's the thing though.
Like I started writing Python when I was 12, you know, and, and I, and around that same
time was when they made the transition on three.
Yeah.
Right.
And people don't realize that like how, well, both how old and how young Python is like.
Yeah.
And, and I, at that point, you know, I was, I was a young, I was a young guy and I was
like, I kind of got my, my head into the Python 2.7 ecosystem.
I was more of a programmer at that point than I was a hacker.
I was just loved programming with Python.
And, um, and I was very against the Python.
I mean, there was a whole sort of resistance movement against Python 3.
Me too, man.
Like, it was so bad.
I was like, you mean I got to put parentheses around my print savings now?
Exactly.
I was so infuriating.
Like, why would you make that, that change?
Like, it's ridiculous.
In hindsight though, I was like, yeah, that was such an outlier.
Like why, why, why wasn't there parentheses around the print savings?
We don't need that.
All we need is our youthful rage, Joel, at the, at the system.
Um, anyway, so I held off on switching to Python 3 for years and then I finally have.
And, you know, now I'm thinking, okay, now I need to learn how to write Rust or Go or
whatever.
So that's going to be on my, what did you say the other day that I didn't know the H2 or,
uh.
H2.
Yeah.
Yesterday I was like, it's, it's the start of H2.
And you were like, what's H2?
And I was like, it's the second half of the year.
It's like corporate speak, man.
I don't know that.
I mean, I barely know what quarter are we in right now?
Like three, right?
Exactly.
We just started.
Thank you.
Um, so anyway, that's on my 2025 H H1.
There we go.
Uh, goals learning to write Rust or Go.
One of the two, but, um, okay.
Let me just finish this segment.
Sorry.
I, I'm derailing.
You really are.
No, you're good.
Um, so essentially we have this, uh, github.com slash Ryan Raider slash reports, uh, repo.
It's written in Python 2.7, literally just handed to chat GPT and converted to Python 3.
I didn't get the chance to do it before this episode.
It's very simple.
All it does is just takes your mark markdown, parses out the templates, allows you to run,
uh, to provide like variables into the templates and also run commands on the command line.
So you can automatically insert stuff like, um, you know, dig commands and then the output
from the dig commands into the report.
Super helpful.
Um, that really helps, but here's what I was going to say before, which was, I have a tool now
to write the reports using AI.
So essentially what it, what it does is, um, it uses this really cool framework called fabric
from, um, Daniel Meisler.
Okay.
And, uh, I, I actually in the doc, I've got my own fork of it lifted, listed here, but it
actually got merged into main, um, uh, yesterday.
So, um, essentially what fabric is, is it's a way the way he describes it is, is the way
to augment humans with AI.
Essentially it's, it's a framework around collecting prompts or they call patterns in
this specific environment.
And, um, allowing you to very easily send data to that via standard in typically.
Um, and, um, and get, uh, the results passed to AI.
So you can, you can pass it to chat GPT.
You can pass it to, uh, Claude.
You can pass it to your own Olama server.
There's lots of, uh, cool stuff that's built into there.
You can have it have context, um, about you as a person.
There was a CD in Olama, by the way.
So don't expose your Olama to the network, but make sure it's up to date.
But yeah, there was, there was just a CD in Olama recently.
I think that's really, I think Olama would be a really interesting, um, thing to go after
because they've got like role-based permissions and stuff like that too.
You can have like users and admins and that sort of thing.
Um, but I wrote this pattern called write, uh, underscore hacker one underscore report.
And essentially what it does is you can provide it with an input that contains requests, responses,
and then comments.
Um, and it will take that and can take into consideration your comments, look at the requests
and the response and write a report for you based off of that.
Um, that fits the hacker one sort of model, right?
You've got like the summary, the details, the steps to reproduce and the impact and like,
you know, various supporting resources and that sort of thing.
Um, and so in order to get everything in the right format for all that, I wrote this other
tool called BB, uh, bug bounty report formatter that's on a github.com slash writer slash BB
report formatter.
Um, and essentially what that does is it allows you to just very easily send in requests, send
in responses, send in comments, and it'll store them in your, on your local system.
And then whenever you tell it to, you can just do use dash dash print dash report, and
it will dump out the, um, report structure.
And then you can just pipe that right into, um, fabric, uh, right hacker one report, and
it will, uh, generate the AI, AI based report.
Now here's the question.
I know you're, you're, it's in your head, Joel.
Okay.
It might be in your head.
It might not be in your head.
Does it actually freaking work?
And the answer to that.
The only thing that's met in my head.
Oh, okay.
It doesn't work.
Well, we'll finish.
I'll let you finish.
The answer to that is sort of.
Oh no.
So it works really well with, uh, chat GPT, uh, for, for, for, for makeup or whatever.
Yeah.
The new one.
It gets great results.
It, I gave it a volume that I had from before that's already closed.
And, uh, it wrote an awesome report for it.
Easy peasy.
I just gave it the request, the response and some description of the volume and it took
it away.
Okay.
But the goal with this whole thing was to be able to do this with private AI, to be able
to do it with old llama on my local system so that it doesn't leak the, yeah.
So that it doesn't like leak the, the, um, report contents.
Yeah.
To open AI.
And that does not work quite as well.
Uh, it works pretty poorly actually.
Um, so I don't know.
I think, I think it's an interesting edge case.
I'm still going to release the tool because some people will use it with chat GPT and that's
fine.
Um, I, I'm definitely looking forward to, to seeing progress in private AI.
Uh, because this really highlighted for me, the difference between a, a system that like,
like chat GPT stuff and something like, oh, llama using like, uh, llama three or llama two
model.
Right.
I mean, the results were just drastically different.
Yeah.
Super interesting.
Um, one thing I did want to mention, and this is completely, this is like the totally wrong
takeaway.
I'm so sorry.
Okay.
You said, come on, what is going on today, man?
I'm just sorry.
You said that, um, to convert Python two to Python three, you should just throw it in
chat GPT.
What are you talking about?
Okay.
There's a built-in tool.
If you don't know this, there's a built-in tool in Python.
It's called two to three, number two, two, number two, word two, number three, two to
three.
And it converts Python two scripts to Python three.
No, it does not.
It does.
That's what it does.
Search it up.
Two to three.
Anyways, just, I'm just leaving that there.
It exists.
Wow.
Check that out.
It's pretty cool.
All right.
I think it's getting removed in like version 3.13 or something.
Oh, really?
But like, if you haven't converted your Python stuff by now, you know.
Very cool.
But yes.
I was going to be mad at you, but that's actually really cool.
Yes.
That is like the one case where I'll say, you don't need to use chat GPT for this.
You can use something much less AI that will probably not get it, start hallucinating halfway
through your script.
Yeah.
No, that makes sense.
Very cool.
Someone should do that.
Maybe I'll do it afterwards.
Maybe I'll do it before this podcast airs.
Who knows?
I got a lot of stuff on my plate this upcoming week, but it would be interesting.
The takeaway there, though, is really worthwhile to have some sort of templating system in place.
And I just kind of use the HackerOne templates and use some of the AI stuff that I've built
in now.
But I think, you know, before when I had this more advanced templating system, especially
if you're reporting very similar bugs time and time and time again, it's very helpful.
And I recently had a scenario where I had to report 25 very, very similar bugs.
And I used report templating and it just saved so much freaking time.
Yeah.
I will say like if you're not doing full-time bug bounty, like, and you don't need to be
like submitting like a lot of reports like in mass like that, like, or if it's not something
that you've like farmed, like if you're reporting, submitting 25 of the same report template
is a great solution for that.
But if you're not a full-time bug bounty hunter, I don't think necessarily that like trying
to shortcut the whole report writing process is a great idea per se.
Like, I think it is kind of like, I mean, to some extent, right?
So like, say you're not like a native English speaker and you're like, I want to make sure
like this is readable.
I think that's a good use case for like, I know, for example, HackerOne has like rewrite
with HAI thing or whatever.
You could maybe do that with chat GPT or maybe Olama just to rewrite it and to make it more
readable.
But like having it generate and like write the report itself, at the end of the day, you're
going to have to reread through it to make sure that it's actually right and that it actually
got everything correct.
And if you're doing that, then you're like halfway there pretty much to just writing the
thing yourself.
Yeah, I don't know.
And like, it is kind of part of the process.
I don't know.
I think it depends on what it is.
Like there should be sort of a line, I think, where like it makes sense to have the AI be
writing a report for you versus just writing it yourself.
Because like, at what point do you like need the AI to write?
Like how much time is it saving you to like collect all this stuff, put it into the AI,
read through what it writes, format that like, you know, it's like, again, you're like probably
50% of the way there.
It helps, man.
It helps.
It does help.
I think for me, like just seeing the way that it worked for my sample stuff that I wrote
associated with this, I literally like took one request, one response, one two sentence,
you know, thing about how to access this thing.
And it extrapolated a bunch of the correct details.
It's like...
What type of bug was it?
It was an IDOR.
And there was another one for Reflected XSS.
Worked great.
Okay.
That's pretty straightforward though, right?
Yeah.
No, absolutely.
And that's the use case where right now, I just don't feel like writing up these super
annoying bugs, you know?
And I just like, okay, just send it off.
All you have to do is just tell the triager, like log into the application, go get this ID
from here and then do this, do that.
And it actually did a really good job.
This is the part that was surprising to me.
Like, the application that I gave it the test data from, it knew about that application.
It's a pretty popular application.
And it was like, oh, you know, this is the functionality in this application.
You can get, log in, go to this spot and then do this thing.
And I was like, oh, wow.
That's like, I didn't tell you about that.
You just kind of knew that.
It's kind of weird that I knew that.
You know, like, yeah.
So I'm sure there will be problems with it.
But I think for me, having to actually get out of my hacker brain and into my writer brain
and start doing that, I think that will be, I think this will be a big time saver for me.
So I've only used it, you know, a couple times.
But I think it'll be helpful.
Yeah, right.
It's like, yeah, for sure.
I agree with you.
I think like it depends on the use case.
And like if you find that use case for yourself where like it makes sense and like it's something
simple like that or it's just like a big time saver where, you know, you don't have a template
that fits it nicely or whatever.
You can't just like copy paste the company name.
It's not something in mass and it needs to be a little more custom than like AI is great
for that or like having something rewrite it for you with just like a little bit of info
is great for that.
Yeah, I agree.
And I wanted to shout out while we're at this segment, I wanted to talk a little bit more
about fabric as well because fabric is pretty rad.
There's a couple other patterns that I use pretty regularly that come in here as well.
The create command one in particular is great.
So you can just say like Echo, write me a command to, you know, a said command to like remove
this or that or the other thing and just pipe that into fabric create command and it will
write that whole command for you.
And I'm like...
Like pipe it together and so...
Yeah, yeah.
And like get it all built out.
That's pretty nice.
And it knows...
I mean, you can give it more context too.
You can give it more like the man pages or whatever and that sort of thing and it will
be able to tie stuff together.
But for stuff where you're constantly trying to like, what was that syntax or whatever,
I think this is really handy.
And the other ones...
So there's clean text, which I think is a really interesting one.
You can kind of tell it, give it some text and it will try to pull out like all of these
weird formatting things and try to get it in a very consistent format.
And I think this is something that, you know, we've all become pretty adept with using like
said, grep, awk, you know, all these things to try to get the text in the right format.
But for the beginner that is just trying to get stuff to be in the right format for like
an intruder list or something like that.
Yeah.
I think this could be really helpful.
Dude, you know, I'm really conflicted about this whole thing because this reminds me of
the conversation that we had with Keith about like the Google effect of this on memory and
learning where it's like, I do think it's worthwhile to like know how to use said or
know how to use awk or know how to like use these fundamental Linux commands to modify and
chain data and not just be like, let me ask the AI how to do this and just have like blindly
copy pasting it. It's like the equivalent of like, you know, Stack Overflow or whatever,
like just like, you know, copy pasting code snippets and just not really knowing what you're
doing. And I think like this is something like I absolutely I want like things to be
easier for people, but I also don't want to encourage like the wrong type of learning
and behavior around this where like this should be something that you should be learning or
using like as a utility to make your life easier, not to like do something you don't
know how to do.
Yeah.
And there's like a line, right? Where like, you know, something's not worth your time. And
then, okay, you probably shouldn't be wasting your time like learning this, but like you're
learning how to use said like, again, like I think like the fundamental Linux knowledge
and stuff that you're going to gain off that is like so much more valuable and more applicable
than like, for example, for example, using it to write a report, like you don't need to
like go learn how to like write like a PhD student in order to write a report, right?
You can just have like that AI do that for you.
But you should learn what the Linux commands that you're using are doing.
There's a limit to that, right?
Like we all have limits to our knowledge.
I know how to use said and awk and cut and all these things very, very fluently.
But I don't know all of these super abstract edge cases for JQ or like, you know, some
of these other applications, right?
But imagine if you did.
Yeah, but I don't, you know, and I've got other things to do besides like, especially
when you're hacking, this is a really important takeaway, I think, especially when you're hacking,
you want to try to remove as much friction as possible to you being able to get to your
goal in the hacking scenario, right?
So for things like this, yes, it's helpful to have that knowledge about said and awk.
And if you want to take the time to learn that outside of being in the zone from a hacking
perspective, then that's great.
But at the end of the day, when you're hacking, you need to stay in your flow and you need
to remove as much friction as possible.
So that's where I think stuff like fabric and integrating these clean, clean text or create
command patterns could be really helpful because it removes that, that, oh, now I got
to go look at the docs, blah, blah, blah.
And now I can just, okay, here's what I need to write.
Copy paste it and go.
Yeah.
Your cat's tail is like right in front of this.
I was going to say, yeah.
I think, you know, there is, right, there's like a line.
I forgot what I was going to say now.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
I remember.
So like, definitely, I would recommend setting aside some time to be able to learn these things,
right?
Like, don't always just say that like, oh, in the effort of like going fast and like not
getting out of flow, I'm not going to bother learning this thing.
And then you'll like never learn it.
I do think it's important to like set aside some time for yourself to learn these types
of things.
So if it's something that you don't want to learn now, but you think that you should learn
later, put it in like a note file or something and then like set aside like one day a week
or something.
If you're a full-time hacker or a couple hours per week or certain times a day where you can
go and you can research those things and not feel the pressure to be hacking, but instead
be learning to improve your hacking and hone it.
Yeah.
What I recommend to my mentees as well is doing that sort of supplemental learning during times
when you can't deep focus on hacking.
So let's say you've got an hour at this cafe while your kid's at their swim lesson or whatever,
right?
Take that hour and instead of trying to like get into a target and in an hour and like
find a bug, which you could, you know, it's possible, especially if you structure your
time properly.
But instead of that, maybe take some time, go learn all these commands, go learn about,
go set up some environment that's going to save you some time and reduce your friction
when you do have focus time, like four hours or something like that, where you can really
be in the zone.
That's sort of my recommendation.
Yeah.
I also love doing that when I'm in constrained environments, like on a plane, on a train,
traveling, in an Uber, like when you're in constrained environments and you're just like,
what do I do?
Instead of scrolling Twitter, go find an article and read through that article because you're
much more likely to actually read through it and occupy yourself than you are to like
do that when you're at your computer and you have a million other things that you can be
doing.
Yeah.
And it doesn't make a difference just that one time, but if you get in the habit of
doing it, like, and you keep on getting in this habit of like, oh, let me read this
article instead of scrolling Twitter, or let me like figure out how to use this Linux command
while I'm, you know, waiting in line at the grocery store or something like that, then that
knowledge will compound, compound, compound, and you're just going to be mega elite at the end.
You're going to be the next Tom nom nom.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
So, all right.
Well, I guess on the, on the note of like taking some time, biting the bullet and setting
some stuff up, I do have a couple of recommendations in addition to what we've mentioned here already.
I always record a POC video.
That's, that's the first one.
Like, unless it's literally click the link, see the popup.
And even then, if it's going to be a bounty above like 500 bucks or something like that,
I'm going to, if it's a bounty that I'm going to be upset to lose, if like the endpoint goes
down or something like that, I'm always going to record a POC video because it's so, it takes
so little time.
It shows proof that the thing happened and it just makes it easier for these triagers that
are skimming reports more and more nowadays.
So one, that's one tip, always record a POC video.
And two, remove friction to recording that POC video on yourself and make it a nice setup.
You know, what I'm using nowadays is OBS and I've sort of, I really liked the way Loom has
their setup in place.
Right.
And I wish I could use Loom, but it, it sends the video out to Loom automatically.
Which is kind of like, kind of meh.
So I kind of set up my OBS to mimic Loom and I've got like a little circle of my face
down at the bottom and I've got, you know, the screen recording on there.
And for some reason, my default setting on OBS, I don't know if you have this as well,
Joel, but it was, it didn't have a pause button by default.
It was like something about the way that it's encoded.
I've got to check my OBS now.
Go check it because it didn't have a pause button.
And I was like, why, why does this not have a pause button?
Because it's super helpful when you're recording a video to be like, okay, now I'm going to
brute force this for 20 seconds.
Be right back.
And you just, you know, press the pause button and then you come back when it's, you know,
done a brute forcing and then you can show the result or whatever.
Yeah.
Do you have it?
No, I don't.
I don't.
I don't think so.
Unless I have to start recording, but yeah, that's, yeah.
I think you might have to start recording with the, like you start recording button down
at the, at the bottom before it pop up.
But I don't know if, because your, your camera and microphone are in use right now.
I don't know if it can do it.
Oh yeah.
I'm not going to, I'm not going to.
Don't mess with it.
But if you don't have a record button, here's the way to get a record button on, not a record
button.
What am I saying?
A pause button on your recordings for OBS.
Go to settings, go to output, go to recording, and then change your recording encoder to X264
and change the output type to MP4 and then save it.
And if you just Google it, there's an article on it.
You know, of course, I just am telling you from the article.
Uh, but essentially that will give you the pause button, just with something with the
way it does encoding.
You can't pause with the normal encoding.
And then that pause button will pop up and you can easily pause, unpause, and you've got
a nice little setup and the triager can see you and it makes a connection and it's very
easy to follow.
So that, that, that's my tip there is like, go ahead and set that up and then reduce as
much, you know, set the auto output directory to be somewhere where you know exactly where
it is and just reduce the friction as much as possible to doing these POC videos.
And then just, uh, just do it every time and have a voiceover as well.
Talk them through it, say, okay, now we're going over here.
We're clicking this button.
Then the attacker is like, you know, doing this thing and just talking them through the whole
flow.
It will really help to understand the full attack vector and it will get your reports to
triage faster and it will, um, even in scenarios, I've actually had triagers be like, Hey, I
can't reproduce this because of X, Y, Z, but I see you have a video and I followed the video.
So I'm going to triage this.
And, and this just saves you that extra time bump, you know?
Yeah.
One thing I will say about the videos.
So if you can't embed your video in your report, like don't, I wouldn't be kidding.
Like for real, because making whether it's the program, whether it's the triage or whoever
have to download your MOV file and like run it on their, like that should give everyone
an ick.
Yeah.
That's yeah.
Please don't do it.
Just embed it.
Yeah.
Embed it in your report.
Don't just attach it as a thing on the end and be like attached is a video record.
Like that literally just feels like a malware email that you've sent me.
Like, please see the attached PDF file and run it on your computer.
Dude.
Like bro.
The report is like, uh, the report is like, um, ability to social engineers, security analyst
into, uh, right.
Open up the video.
Proof of concept.
I'm like, hang on a second.
You just opened this.
Like, hang on a second.
I think I've seen this one before.
Yeah.
But, but, but I mean, I can't imagine anybody doesn't know this, but on, on, on hacker one
and bug crowd.
Oh yeah.
You can embed the videos directly in the report so that you have to do.
And, and not only that, at least on hacker one, there's a built-in screen recorder.
So you don't use OBS.
You don't have a screen recorder set up.
There's a button you can click in the hacker one webpage, like record my screen or whatever.
You can record your screen.
It automatically embeds it right in the thing.
I don't know how well it works.
I've never used it before, but it's there.
And, um, you know, just, you know, give it a shot.
If you don't like it, then you can go through the effort of setting up OBS or some recording
software.
Loom is super easy.
Like you said, like loom is great.
Puts your face there, puts your mouse there.
Uh, it's very user-friendly.
So yeah, there's definitely a lot of options.
Yeah.
Loom.
I've been using a lot recently, um, for sending messages to you, sending messages to the other
members of our staff.
And then Justin communicates to me with videos.
He'll be like, Hey man, are you around?
And I'm like, yeah.
And then he'll just reply with like a video.
I'm like, fuck.
Very true.
Uh, Joel's like, Hey man, what's your favorite color?
And I just said to respond to the loom link.
Like, Hey, so as you can see, I'm a pretty big fan of this shade of red right here.
Uh, but also this one's pretty good as well.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah.
Um, but so let's, dang it.
We are silly today, Joel.
Um, so regarding loom, I, I did, I did want to definitely add this though, that one is
very helpful for sending like collaborating with other hackers.
You can be like, Hey, check out this request.
It literally, you just press the record button.
You record it.
It gets your, it gets your mic, gets your, you know, little face down in the, in the
corner.
It's recording your screen, follows your mouse, all those sorts of things.
And then literally the instant you press stop recording, it generates a link.
Then you can just drop that link in a discord chat or, or whatever.
And it will, and your buddy can like follow along with you.
Exactly.
Um, so that's super helpful for, for, um, collaboration.
And here's what I've been doing with it recently.
That's been kind of a game changer is when I've got to step away from work, um, for the
night or whatever.
And I'm in my zone and I'm like, man, I wish I didn't have to leave.
I'm like in my zone.
Um, just recording a loom video to myself and saying, Hey, um, you think this request, I
was, I always do it in the, in the second person.
Like you think that currently you think that this is really yelling at yourself.
Yeah, this is really weird.
And we should come back to this request.
And, um, so yeah, that's been really helpful.
And then I'll just kind of bookmark it and like put it right in an annoying spot in my
bookmark bar.
So I, I see it as soon as I open up my browser and, uh, and I've watched that video and that
helps me drop right back into the flow state that I was in the last time that I was hacking.
Um, so that's, that's a big, that's a big one, man.
That one really helps.
Yeah.
And I love that.
I mean that in combination with what Ron said he does, and I do this as well, where you
try and leave yourself on like a cliffhanger the night before so that you're really energized
to go hack that the next day.
Um, you know, that's always good to sort of set yourself up for success the next day and
have something to look at and have something to focus on instead of just sitting down and
being like, Hmm, what do I, what should I write?
That momentum is like super important.
So keeping the momentum going like across throughout the evening by sending notes to yourself and
keeping, keeping notes of what you were working on and where you were in that momentum headspace
is really, really important.
Yeah.
I agree, man.
I agree.
Yeah.
That was such a great, a great tip from prawns.
Like I had such an extreme response to that.
I was like, no, that's the moment that you gotta like, that's when you, that's when you crush
the app into the ground.
That's what you have to know.
And no, it's, it makes a lot of sense.
You just leave it.
You leave it is you let, let your brain sort of, uh, reflect on it for the rest of the
night or whatever.
And then the next morning when you need to get up at, you know, 5 AM to go hack before
your kids wake up, you, you wake up and your eyes are like this, you know, your eyes are
kind of squinty.
And then, you know, you remember and you're like, let's go.
Yeah.
I'm going to go hack that thing.
Exactly.
Very real stuff there.
Some people like their coffee in the morning.
I like my, my last night realization.
Joel, what the frick, dude?
Okay.
A couple more, a couple more reporting tips and then we're just going to wrap.
Let's go to putting this stuff at the end.
Otherwise, we might weird people out.
Poor listeners this week, man.
Yeah.
So if this is your first episode of critical thinking that you're listening to, I'm so sorry.
This is not how we normally are.
Um, okay.
So a couple more tips, dude.
I only just found out I've been writing reports on hacker one for seven years at this point.
I just found out recently that you can use syntax highlighting in your markdown blobs.
Yeah.
Recently, maybe like being like two years ago or something like that.
This isn't just a hacker one thing, by the way.
Yeah.
This is a markdown thing.
Um, backtick, backtick, backtick, and then whatever language, right?
So there's one for each J S Java.
There's one for like everything.
Yeah.
Dude.
That is amazing.
It's amazing.
And my, one of my favorite ones is HTTP.
Yeah.
Um, which is a much less well-known one, but it basically is great for highlighting HTTP requests,
the headers and the body and that kind of stuff.
Um, it works especially well on hacker one.
And I think they have some extra stuff added to it that makes it work nicer than it does
in other places.
But you can use this on discord as well.
If you're chatting with your friends on discord and you send them a blah, a code block instead
of just some block of texts, put the language there.
Add some color to it.
It's nice.
Stop it.
Get some help.
It's like, get some help.
Please.
It's like a paint by numbers.
You know, you can do it.
Oh my God.
All you have to do is just add the language.
Okay.
All right.
Um, yeah.
Okay.
Let me ask you this.
Do you always, so just read the whole markdown situation.
Do you always forget how to do a Lincoln markdown or is that like not?
It's now burned into my brain.
I don't know.
Is it?
I just know.
I just know that it's.
I don't know what my problem is with that, but I like always get it mixed up.
So, um, here's a, here's a good way to think about it.
If you were to send someone, if you were to write someone like, Hey, here's this really
interesting thing.
What you would normally do is you would put in parentheses after that, the link.
Right.
Okay.
Be like, Hey, here's this thing.
Parentheses link.
So it's the same in markdown.
You just surround it and you just telling it what the link should be.
It's square brackets and then parentheses adding the context sort of like that sort of
thing.
Yeah.
The link is like, and the square brackets are like link this thing.
Okay.
Could you say that all again, but with a little ASMR, like, okay.
So the first.
Whisper the.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
All right.
That's, that's burned into my brain.
Now that is helpful though.
I think having that parentheses around the, towards the end, I think that that is, that
makes a lot of sense.
Yeah.
Okay, dude, we got to wrap this episode because we're getting too loopy.
Um, the last one, the last, let me just, let me just finish this out.
Okay.
Um, how many times can I derail Justin this episode?
No, dude, no, it's not just you, man.
I got to get a counter going.
I'm going to get a world record.
Yeah.
Um, so last one that I wanted to say was screenshots are also very important in writing your reports.
Um, you should be including those on a really regular basis.
And, um, a lot of, I know a lot of you are just using like the built-in, uh, you know,
windows screenshot or whatever, and, or some like janky Linux one.
Um, I would recommend not doing that, even though I did that for a very long time and
still sometimes do it because of muscle memory and instead get something like green shot.
Where it's very simple.
Like you just, you activate it with a key binding, just like you do with, you know,
the windows screenshotter, you can select very granularly.
You know, it allows you to select down to the pixel.
It's got a little magnifying thing that says, okay, from his pixel, you know, you drag your,
your size for the screenshot and then you can pop it up into like a little screenshot editor
where you can really easily like draw arrows and add text and stuff like that.
And you're not like trying to draw and paint, like do this super jank looking circle and
like this arrow that you drew with your mouse cursor.
And if you're on windows, the best screenshot tool that I can ever recommend is called share
X.
What?
Share X.
Why don't you put these things in the doc?
Dude.
I got to keep these things.
These are top.
These are top secret.
Oh, wow.
This looks top secret tips.
Share X.
Yeah.
I think it's windows only, unfortunately, because it uses a lot of C sharp dot net stuff.
I've tried to cross-cropile it from that before because I liked it that much.
Wow.
But yeah, share X is really, really awesome.
It, you know, it allows you to add blur arrows, rectangles, all sorts of really cool things.
It has like bounding boxes and stuff.
It just copies to your clipboard.
You can do custom upload stuff.
So like if you have an, if you wanted to just like send it to some API endpoint, if you have
a custom image uploader.
No way.
You can do that.
Yeah, you can do that.
You know, you can just have it copied to your clipboard, which is what I usually do.
Yeah.
But yeah, share X is really awesome.
That's what I use on windows for screenshots on Mac.
I just use the built-in screenshot thing.
Preview is kind of okay.
But if you want to add blurs and arrows, what I use is called sketch.
S K I T C H.
Sketch.
Interesting.
Let's add it, add that to the, I'll add it right now.
It looks like this software may or may not exist anymore.
Did they like discontinue or something like that?
Sketch.
Does it have like a little, I can find it.
I can find it like a CNET download links.
Hold on.
I just put it in the, I just put it in the section in the doc.
Did you?
Is that the one?
It's got like a little arrow.
That is the one.
Yeah.
That's it.
I don't know how you found that.
You know, that's it.
Hacker skills, man.
Google dorker.
Sketch.
Yeah.
This one's pretty good.
Oh yeah.
It's made by Evernote.
Yeah.
Oh, is it really?
Oh.
Yeah.
That's one of the reasons I like it.
So it's made by like pretty reputable company.
And so Evernote makes this, yeah, this image editor called sketch.
And you can add blurs.
You can add a little arrows to it.
I think you could probably do it in preview, just the back preview app as well.
But it's blurs.
I don't know about that.
But yeah.
Share X on windows.
Okay.
So that's your recommendation.
My recommendation is green shot.
I'm going to, I'm going to go ahead because you didn't tell me about this before the episode,
Joel, and I didn't get the chance to go and download it and install it and provide my
official recommendation, but we can leave that up to the listener.
Green shot versus what was the one for what windows that you recommended?
Share X.
Okay, cool.
Yeah.
We'll see which one of those gets the better, gets the better review from the community.
All right, dude.
Is that a wrap?
I think we're done, right?
I think that, I think that's a wrap.
All right, dude.
Good luck writing your reports, everybody.
You got this.
Go, go get it guys.
All right.
Peace.